only with the commissions vice
president franz timo renz president
ladies and gentlemen
when i was born it would have been a wild
dream that we would one day decide on our common future in a
european parliament with deputies
from east and west
the wall was built in the year i was born
which for me, like for many
europeans, is closely linked to personal
history
when i was a young soldier
the cold war raged so hurriedly that i was
trained to fight against those
with whom i am now united in a union
in the year the wall
would fall  our son marc was born and when
europe finally became one again with the eastward enlargement in 2004
, our son
max was born
our children, like a whole
generation of young people, have the privilege of
knowing europe exclusively as a continent
of peace, freedom and
unity
and we owe it to them  we also the
peaceful revolution of 1989
it is for mic  h and all those who were lucky
enough to experience the most formative
political event of our lives it
is at the same time the victory of european values
because i the people's longing for
freedom was greater than their fear their
desire for democracy was stronger than their
ideology and their cohesion more powerful
than the regime  in eastern germany central
and eastern
europe it was the civil courage of these people that rewrote the history of our continent and their civil courage was truly european the spark of freedom
was also kindled in the neighbors
at the time with the polish solidarnosc as well
as with the pan-european picnic at the
hungarian-austrian  border around
the baltic way what belongs together grows together
as willy brandt
said
and he meant not only
germany but all of europe we
could also owe this to the
courageous actions of neighbors and
partners who united
germany in the heart of the continent  nts
opened that was not a matter of course at the time
that was not only a courageous step for us president
george bush and ex soviet president michail gorbachev
but was also important for
france and great britain in particular it
meant embedding germany in
europe and adding a whole
new dimension to europe  dare
a europe that puts its two halves
together again that unites western, central
and eastern europe into a single
continent that's exactly what we've been able to
experience in the past 30 years.
i still remember well that before
the wall came down i was able to feel and
see if i  was in the west or east
and that wasn't just because of the special scent
of trabis and gdr cigarettes
when i'm out and about with my
children in east or west europe
today there are still cultural
differences that diversity is
diversity is europe's wealth
you can  but don't look at people
where they come from they are interested s
i deal with the same issues and have the
same worries and hopes and
dreams there is no longer the old and
the new europe in the traditional sense
it is also not the case that the east
would have come to the best we have
grown together into our europe
one of the greatest successes  after the fall
of the iron curtain it was, as water
fable aptly described, that
east and west are no longer moral terms
but have become purely geographical
terms forming the foundation of our image of europe
democracy freedom and human rights
in europe the
rule of law must rule this was and will remain the
main mandate main mandate of the
peaceful revolution
in 1989 freedom and equal
rights for all
unity and justice and freedom
i would say it is the
responsibility of all of us to respect and defend these values
they are they are the product of europe
only in this way could
europe united in solidarity  to a
continental success our
successful domestic market creates
jobs guaranteed access to
education and health insurance and
creates opportunities for each and every one of
those who, in the so-called national
interest, conjure up nostalgia or westalgia or other unprecedented pasts in
order to play east and west in
germany and europe off against each other
, we therefore have to
resolutely
counteract there are still challenges in growing
together we are all aware of that but the fact that
anderson doesn't change anything about the fact that the eu is
the best thing that could have happened to east and west
it must be clear to us who is playing with
europe is gambling away the future
and who is really in the interest of their
national trade wants it backs europe
only together can we play our weight
on the world stage and help shape the rules of the game
if we want to continue the task of the people
from 1989 today, then we would also have to
have European courage
prove and that also means courage in
europe because we can only master the challenges of the
future, from climate change to the
digital revolution,
if we join forces
at the award ceremony for the nobel prize in
1971, willy brandt said that peace is not an
original state, it rather has to
be made by people again and again  will be
decisive for a lasting
peace, above all, social
justice because such fire material need
is concrete and freedom
our common European task
to overcome this remains
to work on it is europe's fate
dear wolfgang
schäuble thank you very much for showing us
what we are fighting for and dear sir
thank you for showing us
we are fighting the consumer bundestag in the
parliament
berlin 19
the logo in europe look very different
files on the realities of the collapse
july in latsch mentor european junior
ladies and gentlemen
despite this great change that was brought about
30 years ago by the m  courageous and
resolute action by the peoples on the
then east side of the iron
curtain we face challenges in europe
some of the achievements in the
european union you can easily take for
granted around the world experience the
tendencies of newer if to build rather
than to slay them
we see the signs of a
real international
cooperation that is being called into question
in such a turbulent and
Unterreichenbach period it is good
to get back to
basics and to remember the basic values ​​that
also led to a great change 30 years
ago,
so i am proud of it here in
europe  saying to parliament that
democracy, the rule of law and
fundamental rights must always be
defended because they are the cornerstones of
the european union, made it
very clear that
authoritarianism, totalitarianism or
nationalism,
our answer, may be
our choice  ll always pay freedom
our choice should always be democracy
and our choice should always be the people
mr schäuble you said that we
share the same values
that's true not just us but
the whole world this world of words they
are the words of the whole world
recognized  from the united nations
ladies and gentlemen
what belongs together now grows together
when the berlin wall fell these were
the wise words of the former
federal chancellor of the
federal republic of germany willy
brandt who was the mayor of
west berlin and also very concrete words
that  europeans had seen division
i am firmly convinced
that the message of unity is also the
key to the success of the
european union we can only be
strong together and we need
a europe that is t1 and not a europe
that separates the promise of the
united europe
thank you very much for your attention thank you very much [applause  s]